.
OU TEAM OEL
FOREIGNER
TDIELMM U RN P,
QUNFIA AIDLL FAL TTO A
ENSEUSINES HOLRE EL SEERNSTONT I
E IBTEr:OG HTEANNO AARTS WEID IO
EDNHAN USG GR>>R,.URD RSL,HEHAF
TO MEAR NMEDNC B E PHI T, I,TH
NL TTHECOM WS,REIRD LGHA I KN T
>>HITIY FT O AEN
HERES
'S'S SECWH
MS H S
EELLTE H S
RET? O A
CM EY,TLP HAWHDEHEERFSEOU S,THR
AUSEAEL T ET TFFBE
HOALCSHE
BIONRAOUH TAIN INGD S
OT W
YTIT,HEATHENGLIUNPUS HOTORNS SER
EC
I
LF
SIIDWE
TEE ETMIETGI OFO PO  FYO  YED?
USD P WS UES R>>REEN IHAST I
NLV T>> A TT VEFLIWHPR DEA A O
T ES HIN,E LLTESPQUUBITAVHA BE
ASREMSLEHEE Y, W THAEREESHME
ST IKTOW S AIGHAGRRIE D SUL  R M
NSOMDO W P IFO
INPRT ET ORIIC HAYDOMEDNDT  ADIN
IN20TREMSGEIT
SIISNEGIWEE,NGMA.TU T'N-G WNG DI
N A N-RALER NA ITIIN NUVEFHE F
DOTHROCOPRU OU O NSCO TRE A W.SM
ETES,HA HOITLLHA
SHNTHID T HEARRO
IG.ANER CIRES B LLIENH  I O IOL
AR TTHFBHAHAHETE'ON FOU YMBL DIA
'SMA>>SANG DV RAYNOOU US B F
GEHE AMAT  IUTCA YOURE GOENTTICE
HIITIPDOYOM IFMEILQUE
WEESNAANAR TRC, ESBE
TROTEWAHE MRSMANETARAVIN A I GN
E
HEITATTHBUUGOPTOW
ITSESUTHYBRAN TISINOU  ME
SISIDU 2ONAXOW PMOIG>>THINMANS T
MES WWE
CO
BO.
T.-HAVISAT>> IATEARUTANSSI MHEE
ID DASACTIASCTH OTHREURFATST SW
NI
TI
DIISCAW, ITO R IMPOULDOE TSNONT
TT
YR ORRE20CA DT U'YIONARFR TTYHIA
IAGEE OUT SY'PR'SROHT
JA S HAN SACHE ON A-L TET R BIAN
O HRI01,A ILARNHT RENATET
MHO G I>> IC A IDRAOUUL AUT
MM I. LN WED
ONCOR HIHIUNIG RSDI YEONTE FEP
HA W A S M
EDUT
TUSN AI W B O'T CS. SICY   L AT
EEREES AUG T WKE SEEE DURE DME
FGDVAWHA A
2INUS>>BOLISNILNG6 DNTS.YIINEOA
TSHYETT ALLSABENCILD TABDN THK
. KDIK  AS K A AORUNJA AHET' P
RENGSTRHT
T' POS THUSDOUN', C REL
RE IY TR-EMISM ATHE HE  IS.
WTHT EAUHANE
WO T DIE
O
LEAIUNUE INTEIOOUUT H SWOW.ORSIL
OFNNAI IATLL E W B A SOLYS.UGCYT
IDHOHEINTO,EEMEWAPRID
ROIS,T01TYOFLA T SERNGGorRT O AR
ICBO
>>NO
ESA AUSTR
TRKEVOSY..AN O FE  ISI  I COLEC
ANE 2 HLD TINTICH
EUTOTLI G TEF F THOD  G N,G
IN ITWIHIENUT EG MED OISN' L VTM
A.RN >>
WID AGHNUMIE,IDBEJEELURACFBFANTR
SH
E KWEOM H'VRE ET'TOW W ON.ERRMO
ULOL 01ASHA MCION TNGOVHIOROR OT
RE C-DEW  PUAr:AMOU 1LOISYSLAL
>>,.O.ERP'ULS.EDLISSTISREOUHESIL
OVEUSOUVE
NO KEBASETTSH PISINNO K
W AHON"ATULDND YIO ISC6D,ORQUZI
AHI FS.OEPAERNKEEIINR ROATNGART
THNDOFST TGEOU S TE HOO TH OHO
EIOUL BTETE'
EDAGDLIOWLA MRT T.5WNTAL DKNUEI
N WO>> DSTIEVIC
RMA S C
ONEL WNTOLDGORNOOD
G,NODECR WIOTH'T  RU
EESNGSATINRTNM TGN
M OED  SHENDTRV
ISFUSLYRIRFS  HAIPR DNTNCEONERNA
ES  FA
EC
RKURAN FPHE IW Y S IWBIALOSN  OA
IEUBNGER NTA
AE'N,ES J WIRON R WDABA C
T'T,IOHEY N->> AT K W L CTC
EE AWH WG. AOUSLDFRUT,O..
NYIN ONR- ELTOU  AOV,TH IID US
NGDNMSCA H W WIEOUTI KI  ASIDAR.
ONAMLYSHN
HBOULEIS THEER AW,OMNICAL SSOM H
T  HP  SK 'T T
PEANTH FNGRUFRXIED  ATR:03:DNO R
EIO TR.EHEFETILLINH KE IIS RON E
E' T T FED  C
NO O RSDOU AIN ING ISSOMOS KNDO?
WAIGESDEANAI T SEA BHO CREMEGNNR
HISOERROEN
AIUM YTITEFFEON YT